cheers Cheers hold on actually actually
I hate it goddamn it
good morning how are you sir thank you
[Music]
oh man I started project I was 15
yep all of Duty yep kind of transition
needs to play professionally yep and
then let's sit out here and out yeah
gather as much attention as you can
right now cuz it will work out the
biggest mistake you could make right now
is get so caught up in the finances even
at this lucrative level where you're
giving up exposure I think of it as
similar to like Mad Dog on Mike in the
Mad Dog he was one of the biggest sports
radio guys with a serious Howard Stern
Howard Stern's decline in culture was
when he cashed down and went to serious
because the less people could hear him
my big belief right now is when you have
something like YouTube and what
Facebook's about to do where you're
getting all the exposure and you're
making some of the money that's [ __ ]
brilliant because you're not in a rush
you're making real money it's not like
like you know everyone's blessed here I
think if you go and do something even if
it's with Netflix like and though
Netflix is probably at scale now but
like the only thing I would say is get
as much exposure as possible create as
little friction for your audience as
possible I think nobody in this space
has really made a go to podcast yet it's
like a top I have a top 100 podcast
that's that shouldn't be I shouldn't
like there are far bigger people you
know people then I will never be that
famous
maybe but I will never I will I will I
will I will definitely use what I could
say if you really made a commitment to a
podcast much like when you're younger
you're gonna have bigger audiences on
YouTube and and back in the day vine or
snap no question podcasters are skewing
older enough we're all the 13 14 15
year-olds are not in play for now in
thirty six months they will be so to me
at this young of an age in this lest of
a situation where you've got it's not
like you're you know back in the day it
was like pay your dues pay your dues pay
your dues that you can cash out your
cashing out now
this is real economics right but think
about what you want to scale to me what
you want to scale is awareness you want
every [ __ ] person here to stop you
basically our end goal every once
the student coming right now he's really
oh [ __ ] or look at you and know who you
are like hit this guy the number one
goal for all of us is that this guy
knows who we are
I agree I agree I'm a big deal big big
deal yes and just any kind of so to me
it's like 100 million [ __ ] whatever
I'm good 200 million start another
channel go do more collapse this I'm
gonna tag the [ __ ] out of you a whole
universe of people who right now is you
know 25 75 year old business people who
are like okay Gary B's gonna go harder
at twitch eSports so for that world I'm
gonna come at in a different way then
your audience comes they're gonna all
inevitably follow you like you and bro
man and ninja like the first five or six
people I do something with are gonna
have business you're inevitably going to
get reached out to just because of this
clip by a fortune 500 company to do
something because this was the seed of
where they became aware of him so this
is exactly right and you need to do that
with hip-hop and skateboarding and moms
and you know just and that's it you've
got a tricky job because as a manager
you want to you know obviously you want
to justify why he's going with you bring
business opportunities but you need to
find the right communication with your
partner's to it's a trade-off of you
can't have both like like in today's
world like the more you cannot monetize
the better every time you ask for
somebody to buy a hoodie or when I asked
for a sneaker right my sneaker right
hook on Instagram is my lowest
performing piece of content no matter
how much value you bring when you ask
for something else that's why I like
things like Adsense and other things
people [ __ ] on them because there's
pennies on the dollars meanwhile I mean
it makes you grow those many as they
become free well yeah your scale but
correct
comma you're losing nothing
whereas when you're like hey everybody
buy my hoodie you're losing something
hey everybody I love this coffee you're
losing something
hey everybody like I might
crypto-currency you're gonna lose
something so you know my biggest advice
this young this early [ __ ] get as
much exposure like make a video that's
called
explaining twitch to moms and then run
it on [ __ ] then take your Adsense
money and run $50,000 worth of Facebook
ads against 40 to 60 year-old women now
you got something you see where I'm
going it's different thinking what do
you do why it's like you want to take a
photo once right and they have no idea
what their kids are engaged nope
and and they're gonna care and they na
demonize technology and video games
under it and for sure that's every
parent's some parents care some don't to
your point that will be a parenting
thing but if you make a video and say
hey mom hey Dad before you jump to
conclusions I think your kids waste your
time I make seven figures a year I did
this I had happiness I was home stuff
like that's you reaching out to that
audience kind of in the reverse of what
I've done
I have always historically skewed more
35 to 75 and I in the last 18 months
have skewed younger because of how I
focused on YouTube or Instagram right
now at which I'm gonna have a whole new
world of people because I'm gonna you
know the same reason all these you know
you know that night the ninja things
going down he's like damn I'm DMing me a
lot of people that are building personal
brands many and twitch already you're
either kind of watching your or really
watching me and a lot of them happens
but I'm gonna bring them value because
I'm only looking to come into the
community for two core reasons one how
do I help the leaders in it
it's cheap what they want whether that's
financial or exposure of fame whatever
and to just create culture moments where
I'm playing old-school games against fun
like just fun [ __ ] right like just talk
a little [ __ ] I'm excited because like
you know people people really funny by
new platforms they're always like oh
you're getting on now and I'm like dude
I was playing paperboy before your mom
before your before your mom was even
thinking about your dad you know like so
it's really fun I'm excited about that
but I see em in it's super meta right
we're just talking about he's you know
video games at eSports and the actual
sport I'm here at the NFL Draft what's
my first meeting with you buddy so
really sport I think that's exactly
right I think that's exactly right we
should go inside
coming
yeah so jiggy let me have it have it off
the Dave take it easy kill it
I will thank you
yeah looking forward together yeah we
can help we'll get so get connected
event everyone take care of funky cities
actually know what you trying to make
more content
that you'll be proud of me I'm making
more content
bonad spotters been there go check my
email real quick
structuring day just did a great meeting
with Preston talking to eSports of a
Dallas woke up 4:00 a.m. this morning
got on a flight got out here to Dallas
that if I'll draft huge day for Vayner
sports in the green room for the first
time big accomplishment this early in
the situation obviously very excited for
Josh Jackson his family big day for him
we'll see where he lands the Jets are
picking third the quarterback of the
future is coming home
so we'll see what that's about got
another little interview here and then
gonna do some Vayner sports stuff we'll
see how much we can film a knock I'm not
quite sure but it's a big fund a little
breaking of the normal patterns vlog but
I'm excited about it really excited
about it and what's cool about this it's
like I've seen this happen to where you
built you put out so much goodwill and
content in the marketplace to where you
don't even need to sell like it it's
done but time people see you there you
know they want to buy versus people like
trying do the opposite of no value in
yourself so that's because I'm a
marketer and a branding guy not a
Salesman
fun of also salesmen look at the earlier
question I asked you you said what are
you gonna do I said itself I know how to
sell I know how to brand the best way to
sell in the world it's not to run
retargeting programs or affiliate
marketing it's build a [ __ ] brand
everybody do you think my man here is
wearing those Nikes because they cook
eat him right like like everybody here
is where everything they're wearing
everything they'd be underwear I'm
[ __ ] witness what is it Calvin Klein
it's [ __ ] brand it's [ __ ] brand
it's all brand that's exactly right I
don't want to ask people to buy my [ __ ]
I want to say I have a new sneaker out
and people buy that [ __ ] I have a new
book out of course and here's the best
part and this is the most important
[ __ ] part in the entire game when I
ask for something
come see me speak come by my sneaker
come by my book I give away all this
free [ __ ] better than anyone I think up
at the top of the game free free if they
don't I understand I have zero
expectations to convert too many people
are giving away [ __ ] for oh when you
give with expectation you're a piece of
[ __ ] you're not a good person when you
give and you have an expectation
you're a manipulator you're not a giver
I give and have zero expectations the
chips will fall where they are if it
goes great Mazel Tov if not I wasn't
providing enough value that's on me I
don't give I'm not doing this interview
for any other reason then I know that
it's leverage for you and it's gonna put
you on and you can use it for other [ __ ]
that you want to do and you know good
that makes me feel that's real life and
I think the cool thing about that is
from a systems point of view that does
not create resentment within you as if
you were giving correct and you
eliminate this I have zero expectations
of everybody I could give a [ __ ]
I've zero expectations of my own
employees what many will argue with me
and my own organization that one of my
shortcomings is my lack of expectations
it's just the way I just have empathy
I'm just overly to a fault I would argue
to a fault empathetic and I've brought
it back to create more accountability
and candor but yeah man that's a you
you're very smart to follow up what I
said by that that was a very good job by
you that's the right insight I'm you
know why I was [ __ ] happy I don't
[ __ ] expect anything from people most
of you are unhappy because you've got
expectations of somebody your mother
your friend what you did at work your
boss your homey I got here when I lend
somebody 20 bucks I may pretend that
shit's gone I'm giving you 20 bucks yeah
it's funny I have one funny question
here I was debating whether to act and
I'm gonna [ __ ] basket and ask I'm
gonna I'm gonna put my two cents but
yeah the question is what was your
payout for your dad's wine business to
build businesses and my answer my - tech
dude it's the work ethic it's the grind
the integrity financially was zero
financially was zero when I let one you
know vaynermedia was started by me
selling a client from Gillette an
$80,000 program and that was the money
that was started the pay I was dick I
zero percent of the business I didn't
get alone nothing I built that business
for my family because my family brought
me to America and raised me perfect and
so nothing the payout was
zero dollars zero that's why when people
talk [ __ ] I laugh I'm competing I
competed against people that raised a
million dollars like you look you were
given a liquor store I sure wasn't then
come and [ __ ] look at my [ __ ]
taxes come see me [ __ ]
I built my [ __ ] parents liquor store
for them facts now come see me when you
got an excuse that easy for you Gary B
you got a three million dollar liquor
store dick face go read the [ __ ]
articles I started in a company that was
doing three million dollars making
300,000 a profit
I worked my dick off from 22 to 30 for
15 hours a day to build a business for
my parents that I left at 34 with
nothing
now tell me who had it worse dick
yeah there I go and that's my thing
right for years I never clarified that
the reason I'm not mad at people for
saying it is I didn't talk about it
because you know was a family business I
didn't know like I didn't want to put my
family's business out there but now I
talk about it with fire because I'm just
tired of your excuses and [ __ ] me who
gives a [ __ ] what I accomplished don't
look at me look at somebody was [ __ ]
born in like the deep jungles of like
whatever and come to America [ __ ]
Asia my parents did it better than me
[ __ ] me my parents give me one nothing
lived in this studio at 23 years old
with $100 [ __ ] forget me there's a
there's 50 million people that came from
dick [ __ ] and [ __ ] made it so what
the [ __ ] your Excuse entitlement
you're [ __ ] entitled if you ever
bought a $5 Starbucks coffee you're
[ __ ] soft if you ever in your life
bought a five-dollar [ __ ] coffee from
Starbucks you are [ __ ] soft globally
in the seven point seven billion people
your [ __ ] fancy your soft a
five-dollar [ __ ] cup of coffee [ __ ]
you
so I don't want to hear it from the
people in my comments or people like
behind my back you live in [ __ ] you
live in like 99% of my comments are from
people in first world countries like
[ __ ] you what your best friend's parents
bought him a BMW and not you you [ __ ]
soft piece of [ __ ] I can't deal with it
it's [ __ ] ridiculous people are oh
you're mad at your homey because they're
parents their parents his parents her
parents paid for their Coachella trip
but you had to work to pay for yours
you went to Coachella
[Music]
like what doesn't matter with you what's
your name
I just walked away both to give my
resume to coffee shops every [ __ ] day
like thank you oh thank you
I'm like really starting from the bottom
line my goodness into your [ __ ] like
your [ __ ] is okay I got this court
chilled like I'm look at that [ __ ]
candy [ __ ] right here right oh my god
you wanna take a photo
yes sir I just was all on my snap who's
like okay okay let me get my [ __ ]
together your [ __ ] looks amazing thank
you
I think I don't have my phone with me
well let's think no we're gonna take a
photo we're gonna email it to you real
give text it to them right now
let's make sure we don't [ __ ] it up no I
was just out today have any kind of
camera camera
place to meet you my guy what's your
what's your number this solo
thank you my gosh you do I hear about a
lot I'm listening to it a lot I'll take
it in I don't have any crazy crazy
questions anything like that I really
feel confident got me yeah yeah I mean
my process just like you 100% mean
you're in the beginning man Thank You
Man thank you for doing that thank you
YouTube my man Matt Matt nice to meet
you boys doing good something you gotta
shoot some videos for your social we're
just doing an interview here I'm in town
for the trap
oh that's nice thank you thank you
this might be the best day of my life
apply just like
guys the lesson we learn today is that
Bobby Bevan I thought we'd have nothing
instead I'd do an interview it becomes
that kind of interview where it just
pops completely and now babban has
something big fan man Thank You Braille
or Jason yep yeah nice peachy man yeah
weird [ __ ] what are you doing here
NFL Draft
it's for four years awesome thanks man
I'm taking it thanks dude
throughout the support and every thank
you guys I wish you well
well mission accomplished thank you
brother
[Music]
yeah at like midnight last night in a
business meeting I'm like Jesus I gotta
leave the apartment at 4 o'clock I'm not
even home yet from this day
you know what it is I keep it actually
very basic to me it's very simple if
your actions don't match your ambition
you're leaving you know a vulnerability
like I'm more than capable of like
working 9:00 to 5:00 if that's what I
want and to me I just love it I love the
action pull of the game you know has it
always been like there was like a moment
where you're like damn this is the same
is it a solution there was one moment
actually but it was actually for the
reverse reason my 30th birthday I was
driving to the wine library the business
my first business and I first you know
it's a weird I can remember like
yesterday I'm literally driving on the
highway and I just I had to look back in
the rearview mirror to like I hurt like
I'm just driving right and I looked at
my rearview mirror and for some reason I
made eye contact with myself and for the
last 15 minutes of that drive on an hour
commute basically he told myself I was
full of [ __ ] even though I'd
accomplished a lot I'm thirty I've built
this 50 million dollar business but it
wasn't mine when I was building for my
family and I was like I kind of just
said bro
if you don't do something soon like all
that hyperbole of like owning the Jets
like you're not even or not you're gonna
become an embarrassment of nothing you
know and that's and that's kind of why I
give the advice of like like all these
kids like I'm gonna be a billionaire I'm
like not if you go to Coachella and you
know as you know not if you don't put in
the work and you can go to Coachella not
if you don't put her to work you know
not and you can go to Coachella
Coachella just you know that's just a
funny thing to reference it's not if
you're not putting in the work not if
you're working in the Soho House for
eight hours but you're really working an
hour you know like you're either working
or not and so and you got to work smart
I was working my [ __ ] ass off on that
thirtieth birthday
it was just I wasn't putting myself in a
position to succeed and so that became
the stuff that was the seed that was the
one time where I was like I'm
disappointing myself I've never been
upset about working hard I've always
been you know I've never been like I've
never felt burned out in my life meaning
I get tired but you're only burnt out if
you don't love it you know
I was I get burned out of doing homework
for one hour in my entire career in
school so I'm an extremist that way
right the reason I was a DNF student the
reason that I don't burn out now is I'm
either it's binary I'm either in my zone
or I'm not and when I'm in my zone
it's a hundred and when I'm not at zero
I'm just not capable and that's why I
think it's also I think I've been able
to be like popular in my humility like
I'm not I can't change I mean like my
ability to not be me is like not
existent I don't have and you know I
don't have it in me work out an
Instagram for you sorry
I just see a scary in two days like
I don't care I get a fine on it I'll
steal with Lee University
those worth leaving school juice chairs
yeah
hold on actually I'm sorry I didn't
think you achieved that I don't think so
either
god dammit Saint Gabriel Gabriel nice to
meet you Memphis
I just want to help your rooster over
depression I get it me too and
depression that's kind of not gonna
we're just gonna have better
conversations around it so that people
can you know what I mean stigma it's not
exactly that's all that's all another
about ending it's about making a [ __ ]
coexist with all the other [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the world you know what's up man of
course
yeah of course that mean you want to
return no worries blaah getting ready
big day at the green suit on you know
why I'm very excited so proud of Josh
and all of our guys so proud of AJ and
Tommy and Brian Druker
a whole team just just a big day in the
process I'm very excited about it really
looking forward to it be a lot of fun
big big day little red carpet little
green room a little postgame we'll see
what happens
we've got a got Josh Jackson we got the
New York Jets I've got some big moments
and friends and family everybody
watching just a lot of fun stuff so
super excited and most of all on a day
like this I'm most excited for Bobby
babban because he woke up this morning
4:00 a.m. thought he wasn't gonna get
any content and he got so much fire he
doesn't know to himself literally bad
but I think at least six Instagram micro
clips from that one interview I was in
rare form anyway
super excited about it fired up let's
see what happens tonight special night
it's me wild
admit it you got way better content than
you expected
did you underestimate me a little bit
and what happened it turns out you're
really famous in Dallas
[Music]